c'est une petite fille d'une dizaine
d'années
depuis la fin de l'année 2022 elle
apparaît sur les images de la propagande
nord-coréenne à côté de son père Kim
Jong-un
elle salue les militaires lors des
défilés
elle a déjà un timbre à son effigie
elle est présente lors des lancements de
missiles
le message est clair pour la dynastie la
Corée du Nord doit rester une affaire de
famille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à l'été 2022 une jeune femme prend la
parole dans le grand hall du peuple à
piani
la camarade teammio Jong chef du Comité
central du Parti des travailleurs de
Corée va prendre la parole
[Applaudissements]
je suis ici pour passer en revue les
jours ardents de notre lutte contre la
pandémie pendant les 91 derniers jours
de nombreux drames ont eu lieu sous mes
yeux la mémoire de ces événements
provoque en moi une émotion
indescriptible
la jeune sœur du dictateur nord-coréen
tous les officiels du secteur de la
santé sont face à elle et face à Kim
Jong-un
je n'oublie pas les moments tourmentés
où je ne pouvais être d'aucune aide
autre que de voir le grand leader
parfois désorienté et attristé face aux
dangers qui menaçaient le peuple je me
sentais tellement coupable de ne pas
pouvoir soulager c'est lourdes
responsabilités qu'il portait seul
membre du bureau politique responsable
de la propagande de son grand frère elle
est considérée comme la numéro de du
régime
pendant de longues minutes face à un
auditoire qui n'a pas peur d'afficher
ses émotions elle explique comment elle
a pu avec son frère gérer le pays
pendant l'épidémie de covid
[Applaudissements]
craignez en Corée du Nord on ne va
jamais publiquement assumer que le pays
fonctionne selon un système féodal
personne n'oserait parler de famille
royale alors on utilise le concept de la
ligne du Mont pectou pour justifier la
succession dynastie
les membres du parti et les jeunes
nord-coréens vont régulièrement rendre
visite à cette montagne sacrée pour le
régime on y découvre les lieux de combat
de la résistance anti japonaise de Kim
ils sont où le prétendu lieu de
naissance de Kim Jong-il c'est une sorte
de pèlerinage le pouvoir du fondateur du
régime est ainsi sanctifié en Corée du
Nord
[Musique]
dans l'irrationnel le mont pectou est
devenu l'équivalent de Bethléem pour les
chrétiens
grâce à la légende du Mont pecdo une
famille s'est installée au pouvoir en
Corée du Nord elle a privatisé un pays
entier à son service
une dictature familiale qui prend
l'apparence d'un régime communiste
saupoudré de surnaturel
[Musique]
coréen je vous annonce solennellement la
naissance de la grande étoile brillante
qui est mis sous le mont pectou
la grande étoile qui nous porte bonheur
c'était levé annonçons cette grande
nouvelle au monde entier
[Musique]
la propagande nord-coréenne répète le
message en chinois en japonais en
espagnol et bien sûr en anglais pas
vraiment pour convaincre le reste du
monde plutôt pour faire croire au coréen
que leur leaders sont également vénérés
à l'étranger
en montant sur le mont pectou la
montagne révolutionnaire sacrée kimisung
a déclaré avec une grande émotion
[Musique]
je pense aux camarades qui me Jong-il le
mont pectou et son lieu de naissance et
le berceau il a forgé son courage
[Musique]
de timilsung
prend une décision importante ou quand
il affronte une difficulté on le voit
monter sur le mont pectou
il se fait prendre en photo sur un
cheval blanc
c'est pour rappeler le souvenir sacré de
simulation et Kim Jong-il
c'est pour s'inscrire dans leur
mythologie
[Musique]
la direction du pays est assurée par la
dynastie au grand complet
sur scène face à l'Assemblée nationale
populaire on retrouve le grand-père qui
mitsoung son fils Kim Jong-il son
petit-fils qui me Jong-un enfin sa
petite fille qui me jonc
chacun son tour dirige la Corée du Nord
depuis 1948
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette lignée du bon pecdo commence donc
avec 10000 SuG le fondateur de la Corée
du Nord en 1948
[Musique]
il restera au pouvoir jusqu'en 1994 l'un
des plus longs règne du 20e siècle qui
lui permit d'imaginer son régime à son
image grâce à un culte de la
personnalité unique au monde
[Musique]
officiellement
kimilong dirige toujours le régime car
il a été nommée président éternel à sa
mort
[Musique]
en 1994 c'est son fils Kim Jong-il qui
prend la relève
[Musique]
pendant une vingtaine d'années il avait
été le second du régime de son père
officiellement il est né sur le mont
pectou
et il serait doté de capacité
intellectuelle unique au monde
[Musique]
est un philosophe un homme d'État et un
dirigeant exceptionnel doté de talents
et de capacité unique
il n'est pas seulement le plus grand
génie idéologique et théorique de notre
époque il est également le plus grand
homme que l'histoire humaine et jamais
produit le plus grand des hommes
excellents dans tous les domaines
[Musique]
team jongil meurt en 2011 et c'est son
plus jeune fils qui me Jong-un 27 ans
qui lui succède
pour beaucoup son âge est un handicap
pour diriger le pays où les compagnons
de route de son grand-père sont nombreux
dans l'appareil du régime alors il va
tout faire pour s'inscrire dans les
traces de son grand-père qui m'illum
[Musique]
il était très jeune dans une société où
le respect de l'âge compte énormément il
y a du réseau de ce problème nouveau
pour lui et pour le régime
alors il a essayé de compenser en
s'habillant de manière très
conservatrice son apparence s'inspire
directement de celle de son grand-père
malgré son jeune âge que je t'ai acte
[Musique]
personne ne le connaissait et il est
apparu d'un coup comme ça au milieu de
nulle part mais en fait il ressemble
drôlement à Kimi song son grand-père
alors les gens ont commencé à se
demander qui c'était est-ce qu'il est de
la famille
à chaque apparition publique Kim Jong-un
se comportait et parler exactement dans
le moindre détail comme son grand-père
[Musique]
on découvre
un dirigeant qui prend la parole avec
beaucoup de facilité qui s'exprime qui
explique
qui n'hésite pas à convoquer le Congrès
du Parti des Travailleurs il va le faire
très vite et très régulièrement
expliquer ça sa politique
jusqu'à passer d'ailleurs pour je le
mets entre guillemets toutefois pour un
réformateur et à créer d'ailleurs
certaines attentes de la communauté
internationale sur sa capacité
finalement à accepter de dialoguer et
surtout sur sa capacité peut-être à
assurer un développement économique et
donc modifier les conditions de vie de
la de la population
pour consolider son pouvoir Kim Jong-un
ne va pas hésiter à purger une bonne
partie de la vieille garde du régime
qu'il soupçonne de manque d'enthousiasme
à son égard notamment son oncle Johnson
tech dont la mise à mort en 2013
officiellement pour corruption montre
clairement que personne n'est à l'abri
[Musique]
la presse officielle qui d'habitude ne
publie que des bonnes nouvelles
participent à l'exécution publique du
plus vieux membre de la famille Kim
[Musique]
ouais
succédé à son père nous avons appris que
c'est un jeune homme qui était allé à
l'école en Suisse
nous avons pensé que c'était peut-être
une personne plus cosmopolite qui
comprenait la communauté internationale
nous avions
tortif des trois Kim qui ont dirigé le
pays
[Musique]
enfin le dernier dictateur de la
dynastie qui m'installe ses proches au
cœur du pouvoir
a commencé par sa soeur qui me Jong
lorsqu'ils étaient enfants ils ont vécu
ensemble sous un faux nom pendant
plusieurs années en Suisse scolarisé
dans des écoles chics de Berne
[Musique]
depuis cette époque leur confiance
réciproque est totale
et la jeune sœur deviendra la région du
régime si son frère ne pouvait plus
exercer le pouvoir
tout est prévu pour que la famille garde
la main sur le pays
[Musique]
en Corée du Nord il y a deux systèmes
juridiques d'abord on a une constitution
qui dit que la Corée du Nord est une
république qui devrait élire le
Président par le biais d'une élection
universelle mais il y a une deuxième loi
ce sont les statues du parti
et que disent ces statuts le leader du
parti vient de la famille Kim de
génération en génération
ainsi le parti est basé sur l'idéologie
de kimilung et de Kim Jong-il et il doit
travailler non pas pour la patrie ou
pour le peuple nord-coréen mais pour la
succession de la famille Kim c'est noir
sur blanc c'est écrit et c'est clair
pour tout le monde
évidemment les statues du parti prime
sur la constitution
en Corée du Nord quand on entre dans le
parti on fait un serment on entre dans
le parti en jurant qu'on va tous
sacrifier pour permettre la succession
de génération en génération et c'est
selon ce principe que le système
nord-coréen fonctionne
[Musique]
de la naissance jusqu'à la mort
chaque nord-coréen doit ainsi une
fidélité absolue à la famille Kim
la propagande diffuse des images d'une
population radieuse
mais la réalité est beaucoup plus
compliquée
chaque nord-coréen est chargé
d'espionner son voisin
[Musique]
les collègues se dénoncent à l'usine
les clients surveillent les vendeurs
[Musique]
les époux peuvent s'accuser
réciproquement devant la sécurité
publique
le régime s'est inspiré des méthodes
soviétiques qui la poussée à l'extrême
pour vérifier que personne n'oublie de
sourire sur les photos officielles
on crée une unité de 5 familles qui vont
se surveiller entre
elles-min Man qui regroupe une
soixantaine de familles et il y a un
chef de cette indemine
ce chef va gérer ses foyers et doit être
au courant de ce qu'il se passe dans
chaque foyer
c'est un système de surveillance de
proximité et il existe depuis très
longtemps depuis 75 ans
et ce système est toujours actif
est désormais devenu un système de
terreur absolument horrible dans lequel
chacun doit critiquer et mettre en
danger ses propres voisins
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de société civile il n'y a
pas d'université ou de religion ou de
structures qui permettent souvent au
mouvement sociaux d'exister
le régime nord-coréen a tout interdit
[Musique]
en Corée du Nord il est ainsi impossible
d'émettre une opinion qui ne soit pas
dictée par la volonté du parti vos
collègues vos voisins et même votre
famille risque de vous dénoncer
[Musique]
un adolescent coupable d'avoir tenté de
regarder squid game une série
sud-coréenne ainsi été dénoncé par ses
parents puis condamné à mort
en dénonçant leur fils les parents
espéraient échapper à la condamnation
[Musique]
en Corée du Nord quand on punit une
personne on punissait membres de sa
famille également si un fils d'une
famille a été fusillée pour un crime
contre la patrie ses parents frère et
sœur voir ses camarades seront également
sanctionnés et discriminés si
on peut avoir des envies de justice pour
se dire je veux sacrifier ma vie pour la
liberté de la démocratie de ce pays
mais si on sait que ces neveux ou ses
parents ou sœur seront en danger à cause
de ses propres convictions politiques
est-ce qu'on passe à l'acte tout de même
c'est pour ça qu'on n'ose pas s'exprimer
en Corée du Nord
le régime nord-coré actuel
si vous êtes quelqu'un qui veut
désespérément libérer son peuple en
Corée du Nord peut-être que s'il n'y a
que votre vie qui est en jeu vous diriez
que vous êtes prêt à mourir pour cela
pour libérer votre pays
mais êtes-vous prêt à faire tuer vos
grands-parents vos enfants vos tentez
vos oncles
c'est donc cette façon terrible qu'à le
régime de contrôler sa population
une fois qu'on est considéré comme une
menace qu'on enquête pas plus on tue au
premier abord sans procès sans défense
c'est ça qui est différent en Corée du
Nord
c'est pour ça que Kim Jong-Un a pu tuer
son oncle John Santec et son demi-frère
son demi-frère Kim jongnam a été
assassiné dans un aéroport devant les
yeux du monde entier devant une caméra
de surveillance il a osé tuer son frère
rien ne peut l'arrêter
le 13 février 2017 à l'aéroport de Kuala
Lumpur deux jeunes femmes enrôlées par
les services secrets nord-coréens
asperges le frère aîné du dictateur de
pionniers d'un agent neurotoxique
[Musique]
il va déclencher sa mort en quelques
minutes
on retrouvera 120 000 dollars dans son
sac à dos les Nord-Coréens impliqués
dans la tête restent à ce jour impuni
Kim jongnam vivait depuis plus de 10 ans
exilé en Asie du Sud-Est éloigné du
système dynastique mais il représentait
toujours une menace potentielle pour son
petit frère désormais au pouvoir
[Musique]
pour ceux qui échappent à la pleine de
mort il existe une vingtaine de camps de
travaux forcés à travers le pays selon
les observations des satellites
occidentaux
d'après les rares rescapés qui ont pu
fuir le pays les conditions de détention
et de travail sont les plus éprouvantes
au monde
la majorité des détenus meurt à la tâche
notamment dans les mines du pays
selon une commission d'enquête de l'ONU
plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'opposants sont morts dans ces camps et
des millions de Coréens on périt dans
les famines des années 80 et 90 la Corée
du Nord est ainsi depuis des dizaines
d'années la dictature la plus cruelle au
monde pour son propre peuple
[Musique]
quand je suis arrivé en Corée du Sud on
m'a expliqué qu'il existait un comité
national des droits de l'homme et je ne
comprenais pas ce que c'était je connais
le mot comité le mot national mais je ne
connaissais pas le concept des droits de
l'homme j'ai demandé donc ça veut dire
quoi tout le monde était surpris
vraiment tu ne sais pas ce que sont les
droits de l'homme on m'a expliqué que ce
comité était une organisation faite pour
protéger les droits qu'on a en tant
qu'être humain alors j'ai demandé
pourquoi on m'a dit c'est normal il n'y
en a pas en Corée du Nord
[Applaudissements]
il ne comprenait pas le principe de la
plainte N2 nous avons interrogé environ
60 femmes nord-coréennes
c'était un mot inconnu pour elle
se plaindre ne fait pas partie du
vocabulaire donc il a fallu tourner
autour du mot pour leur expliquer ce que
ça veut dire elles nous ont dit ce n'est
pas possible de se plaindre
l'Union des Femmes peut se plaindre de
vous si vous n'avez pas atteint vos
objectifs
mais pour elle une plainte ne peut aller
que dans un sens
le gouvernement peut punir ou critiquer
les gens pour ne pas satisfaire à
certaines de leurs obligations remplir
leur quota par exemple
ne peut se plaindre donc elle ne
comprennent pas que dans un pays normal
les citoyens ont le droit de se plaindre
[Musique]
la Corée du Nord peut ainsi être un
enfer Pour sa population
[Musique]
pourtant la capitale pionnier semble en
pleine modernisation
la ville est immense longeant pendant
des dizaines de kilomètres la riveté
donc l'un des principaux fleuves de
Corée du Nord
[Musique]
les monuments officiels occupent
l'essentiel du centre-ville
[Musique]
le ministère de la Guerre rappelle les
grandes dates du pays
[Musique]
le palais du soleil et le cœur du
pouvoir et l'endroit où l'on organise
les grandes parades officielles
de l'autre côté de la rivière La Tour de
jutsche c'est le nom de l'idéologie
officielle qui affirme l'importance de
l'autosuffisance
c'est le mantra de la dynastie
[Musique]
depuis l'avènement de Kim Jong-un
pyongyang a clairement repris des
couleurs
c'est l'engagement du jeune leader qui a
compris que son pouvoir ne pouvait pas
seulement dépendre de la répression mais
également de l'amélioration visible de
la vie de son peuple
depuis son arrivée au pouvoir Kim
Jong-Un a choisi de mettre l'accent sur
le développement des armes nucléaires et
des missiles
militaire classique semblant partie
détourné pour améliorer le secteur
économique privé
ainsi on remarque que l'industrie légère
se développe sous Kim Jong-un
même si la vie a Pione Yang en province
sont bien différentes les Nord-Coréens
semblent avoir changé dans les rues de
la capitale
le régime impose des règles mais
l'apparence est plus sophistiquée
les téléphones portables se sont
généralisés même si on ne peut pas
appeler l'étranger
il y a plus de voitures dans les rues
parfois presque des embouteillages face
aux traditionnels agents de la
circulation de pionniers
même si le vélo est toujours aussi
populaire
certains quartiers de la capitale
tentent de ressembler à une ville
presque comme les autres
une modernité qui contraste avec les
habitudes du passé
en Corée du Nord s'est significativement
améliorée pour le peuple au cours des 30
dernières années bien sûr on part de
loin mais il y a eu une amélioration
le peuple disons ordinaire a des
possibilités totalement différentes en
matière de consommation
il y a plus de choix pour s'habiller
plus de choix pour se nourrir
plus de choix pour se déplacer
modernisé
dans tout le pays et je peux dire que
ces améliorations sont générales
bien sûr est un cas à part
et la direction du pays
du soutien de ses élites pour maintenir
la stabilité politique
les réfugiés préfèrent Kim Jong-un à son
père
il sentent que leur niveau de vie
s'améliore contrairement à Kim Jong-il
qui ne pensait qu'à l'armée
le côté économique et tout il a libéré
et promu le marché
donc les habitants nord-coréen ont plus
d'espoir et d'attente pour Kim Jong-il
[Musique]
chaque soir cette belle histoire d'un
pays en plein développement le journal
télévisé diffusé sur toutes les chaînes
ne manquent aucune occasion de célébrer
l'ouverture d'une nouvelle usine
ils ont fait l'objet d'une intense
couverture médiatique le grand leader
lui-même tenant à les essayer en
personne
du bien-être des habitants de la
capitale
[Musique]
il y a un progrès énorme dans
l'audiovisuel en Corée du Nord c'est
devenu plus moderne et plus visuel par
exemple les techniques de montage plus
rythmées dynamise maintenant le rythme
des émissions
a en effet visiblement intégré les codes
et les savoir-faire des télévisions
étrangères pour moderniser ces
programmes pour les rendre plus crédible
aux yeux des téléspectateurs
[Musique]
une figure ne change jamais
a pris une photo souvenir avec les
travailleurs de la télévision centrale
de Corée qui ont su assurer des
reportages de grandes qualités
présentatrice du journal télévisé depuis
le début de la dynastie Kim apparaît
toujours sur les écrans pour annoncer
les informations les plus importantes
mais aussi la rencontre entre Kim
Jong-un et le personnel de la télévision
[Applaudissements]
entre le régime et ces médias n'est pas
un secret en Corée du Nord
quelques jours après cette photo Kim
Jong-un inaugure un ensemble d'immeubles
d'habitations
ultra moderne
[Musique]
les Pelous sont parfaites la population
est au nirvana le grand leader lui-même
va offrir les clés de son nouveau
logement à la présentatrice vedette des
informations ainsi récompensée de sa
fidélité au régime
[Musique]
le cher camarade Kim Jong-un m'a dit
qu'il n'y a rien de plus précieux qu'une
travailleuse qui a consacré 50 ans de sa
vie aux médias de la République
populaire démocratique de Corée
du Nord il y a des médias et la fonction
de ces médias n'est pas du tout la même
que celle que nous connaissons les gens
qui travaillent dans les médias se
nomment fièrement les clairons de la
Révolution ils en sont très fiers
il considère que le rôle est de soutenir
la révolution d'améliorer l'image du
grand leader et de mobiliser la
population donc de jouer le rôle d'un
haut-parleur le plus efficace possible
la propagande propose régulièrement de
grands événements organisés dans le
centre de pionniers parfois des défilés
militaires mais le plus souvent des
parades ou des événements civils
ce jour-là le jour du soleil ce sont les
organisations de la jeunesse et des
étudiants qui proposent un grand bal en
costume traditionnel
l'événement a visiblement pris des mois
à être chorégraphié dans le moindre
détail
[Musique]
l'enjeu est à ce point important pour le
pays qu'il y a un budget énorme
là-dessus
c'est une des nouvelles approches de Kim
Jong-un
il semblerait qu'il accorde beaucoup
plus d'importance aux cérémonies
nationales pour donner du prestige pour
le parti et asseoir le régime auprès des
habitants
la Corée du Nord que Kim Jong-un dirige
devient de plus en plus forte vous vivez
dans ce pays bien puissant et bien
contrôlé nous sommes en train de nous
développer c'est pour faire passer ce
genre de message qu'il fait ce genre
d'effort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
plus on va à la génération suivante moi
on peut prétendre à la légitimité c'est
normal les souvenirs du passé deviennent
de plus en plus vague son grand-père a
mené des combats indépendantistes contre
les Japonais ils pouvaient s'appuyer sur
cette image mais 8 décennies sont passés
depuis la guerre la légitimité ça fait
fonctionner c'est humain
c'est pour ça
pour trouver de nouvelles sources de
légitimité
nord-coréenne n'hésite plus à mettre en
scène ses propres progrès pour assurer
la propagande du régime de Kim Jong-un
mais ces progrès s'expliquent également
par la volonté de contrer l'influence
des vidéos importées de Corée du Sud
officiellement il n'y a aucun moyen de
recevoir la télévision de Séoul en Corée
du Nord
officieusement les feuilletons
sud-coréens et les stars de la Kpop
s'échangent sur des clés USB
[Musique]
en Corée du Nord je regardais pas mal
d'enregistrements sud-coréen et
américains quand j'étais jeune et en
2016 j'ai eu le droit au contrôle du
ministère de la Justice
portable qu'au minimum j'encourai 10 ans
de travail forcé et au maximum la peine
de mort c'est pour ça que je me suis
échappé du pays j'avais 27 ans
pour lutter contre les influences
extérieures au pays interdire les
télévisions étrangères ne suffit pas il
faut isoler complètement la population
du reste du monde évidemment les
Nord-Coréens ne peuvent pas voyager à
l'étranger ils ne peuvent pas non plus y
connecter
au début quand les téléphones portables
ont été introduits dans le pays on a
utilisé un réseau conçu à l'étranger au
lieu d'un réseau indépendant nord-coréal
avec ce système on pouvait mettre des
cartes SD ou autre sur le téléphone sur
lesquels on pouvait télécharger des
vidéos Sud coréennes et des films
américains du coup les autorités se sont
dit que ce n'était pas une bonne chose
du jour au lendemain ils ont recréé un
système d'intranet plus fermé
[Musique]
pour l'informatique il savait que
l'avenir en dépendait
avec cette technologie et la
communication son régime peut
s'effondrer
donc il fallait séparer à tout prix son
pays de la communauté internationale
à l'heure actuelle il n'y a toujours pas
d'internet en Corée du Nord il tenait
[Musique]
je viens d'Allemagne de l'Est je peux
donc comprendre les comparaisons entre
les deux Corées quand je vivais à Berlin
Est jusque dans les années 90 nous
pouvions chaque jour voir la télévision
de l'Ouest nous avions des visiteurs de
l'Ouest nous pouvions nous appeler au
téléphone
de la Corée du Sud est très différent
ils peuvent regarder une série ou
entendre une rumeur de temps en temps
mais il n'y a pas d'influence
quotidienne
je pense que la plupart des Nord-Coréens
n'ont pas la moindre idée de la vie en
Corée du Sud même si les moyens
d'information évoluent un peu
à l'automne 2020 le régime a promulgué
une nouvelle loi qui promet l'exécution
sur la place publique pour ceux qui
seraient en possession de contenu
sud-coré il est interdit de rêver à une
vie meilleure au sud
il est interdit de rêver à la
réunification
une politique répressive qui fonctionne
car le flux de réfugiés est passé de
plus de 1000 personnes en 2019 à
seulement une dizaine en 2022
[Musique]
quand on regarde les journaux officiels
nord-coréens il est devenu difficile de
tomber sur les articles qui parlent de
ce qui se passe de l'autre côté de la
frontière
par le passé sur la page 6 du journal de
Redon il y avait toujours des nouvelles
de la Corée du Sud mais depuis 2020 on
ne les voit plus les Nord-Coréens
considèrent que les Sud-Coréens sont les
mêmes coréens queues mais beaucoup plus
riches c'est ça l'image donc les
autorités nord-coréennes contrôlent au
maximum les informations sur la Corée du
Sud
[Musique]
pour les 26 millions de Coréens la vie
s'écoule ainsi selon un plan défini
depuis plus de 70 ans
3 ou 4 générations après la fondation de
la dynastie Ie Kim le pays ressemble à
une gigantesque secte ou toute
résistance à l'ordre établit semble
avoir été vaincu grâce notamment à un
embrigadement qui commence dès le plus
jeune âge
[Musique]
dès le plus jeune âge dès qu'on va à
l'école maternelle on apprend que c'est
la famille Kim qui dirige le pays
commencent la journée en saluant et en
remerciant les portraits de Kim Jong-il
et de kimmilsung
ce lavage de cerveau ne se fait pas en
quelques jours mais dès le berceau
jusqu'à la tombe
[Musique]
entre 6 et 15 ans tous les jeunes font
partie de la Ligue coréenne des enfants
c'est l'organe du Parti des Travailleurs
chargé de l'endoctrinement dès l'école
primaire
[Musique]
vers 10 ans chaque jeune membre venant
de tout le pays est accueilli
officiellement par le parti lors d'un
jour férié
[Musique]
les garçons et les filles portent le
foulard rouge des jeunes pionniers
le grand leader préside les cérémonies
les Nord-Coréens considèrent qu'il
s'agit de la journée la plus importante
de l'enfant
l'émotion est souvent difficile à
contenir
[Musique]
à 17 ans l'ensemble des jeunes garçons
est enrôlé par l'Armée populaire de
libération
le service militaire va durer jusqu'à
leur 30 ans
près d'un coréen sur 10 fait ainsi
partie de l'armée
la quatrième du monde avec plus d'un
million d'hommes
une armée qui dispose de peu de moyens
une armée dont le matériel est souvent
très âgée
mais une armée qui compte sur
l'endoctrinement des soldats
[Musique]
dont l'état d'esprit combattant et
régulièrement souligné par la propagande
[Musique]
s'il te plaît
la situation économique de la Corée du
Nord est difficile la population peu
nombreuse
la Corée du Sud et les États-Unis l'ont
ignoré et sous-estimer depuis longtemps
et même aujourd'hui ils disent que la
Corée du Nord n'est rien sans ces armes
nucléaires
mais les nord-coré ont toujours eu un
esprit de résistance ils ont
naturellement et historiquement un
esprit solide et un instinct de survie
en plus ils sont éduqués sous un système
dynastique complètement coupé du monde
extérieur
ils ont une forte loyauté envers leur
pays donc leur niveau d'engagement n'est
pas le même qu'en Occident tout ce
qu'ils font c'est une question de vie ou
de mort
la population est ainsi prête à tous les
efforts pour soutenir le régime
le programme nucléaire a englouti une
bonne partie des moyens du pays mais le
sacrifice semble naturel au nord coréen
je suis entré dans l'armée en 1993 en
Corée du Nord j'ai appris le mot
nucléaire à ce moment là
a appris pour la première fois on nous a
dit
les envahisseurs américains salivent
pour attaquer notre beau pays
et guette encore une fois la possibilité
de nous envahir avec des armes
biologiques bizarres
pour nous protéger nous-mêmes il faut
qu'on ait les armes nucléaires
voilà comment on nous l'a appris
de la bombe hydrogène qu'on peut
installer sur un missile balistique
intercontinental est une réussite totale
depuis chaque essai nucléaire chaque
lancement de missiles sont l'occasion de
grandes célébrations par la propagande
si on arrête de dire qu'on a lancé des
missiles et renforcer les exercices
militaires l'idéologie va s'effondrer
les gens vont se révolter c'est du
lavage de cerveau permanent pour
soumettre le peuple
il faut donc en permanence mettre en
scène les progrès de l'arsenal nucléaire
en avril 2022 la Corée du Nord organise
l'un des plus grands défilés militaires
de son histoire
la vedette du jour la voici
[Musique]
le wasong dit c'est énorme missile
balistique intercontinentale capable
d'envoyer plusieurs ogives nucléaires
n'importe où sur la planète
pour le régime c'est une assurance vie
pour Kim Jong-un l'aboutissement d'une
promesse qu'elle avait fait à son peuple
quatre ans plus tôt
[Applaudissements]
ou les États-Unis ne pourront jamais
oser déclencher une guerre contre nous
la totalité du territoire américain et
désormais à portée de nos missiles
nucléaires et le bouton de lancement se
trouve juste sur ma table ce n'est pas
du tout un chantage c'est la réalité
fin 2017 Kim Jong-Un a déclaré que le
programme de développement nucléaire
nord-coréen était enfin abouti
et un mois plus tard il a réaffirmé dans
son discours du Nouvel An il dit avoir
accompli le testament de ses
prédécesseurs
[Musique]
c'est que le pays a atteint son but
ultime devenir une puissance nucléaire
c'est à dire une puissance pratiquement
inattaquable même par les États-Unis
qui me Jong-un explique aussi que le
programme nucléaire nord-coréen ne date
pas d'hier
il a été imaginé par son grand-père qui
m'illum le fondateur de la République
populaire démocratique de Corée
dans les années 30 qui m'insung est un
militant nationaliste coréen qui lutte
contre la colonisation japonaise il est
d'abord formé par le Parti communiste
chinois puis par l'Union Soviétique où
il est réfugié pendant une partie de la
seconde guerre mondiale
en 1945 il a 33 ans lorsque le Japon
capitule rendant sa souveraineté à la
Corée
une capitulation longue à se dessiner
qui n'a été possible que par la première
utilisation de la bombe atomique a
Hiroshima et Anna gazaki
kimilsong est ainsi au premier loge pour
comprendre l'intérêt de cette nouvelle
arme
le cas du Japon bien entendu est
important dans l'appréciation
nord-coréenne de l'intérêt d'un
programme nucléaire le Japon a été forcé
à la capitulation par deux frappes
atomiques sur Hiroshima et Nagasaki les
6 et 9 août 1945
pour les Coréens cela signifie la fin de
la domination japonaise coloniale chez
eux
il a suffi pour cela de deux bombes deux
bombes pour mettre le Japon à genoux
[Musique]
la conclusion était naturelle l'arme
atomique est la plus importante
après Hiroshima les Japonais qui
colonisaient la péninsule coréenne
capitule et rentre au Japon les troupes
soviétiques
occupent alors le nord du pays jusqu'au
38e parallèle
plus au sud ce sont les Américains qui
sont les forces occupants d'un pays qui
n'a plus été indépendant depuis la fin
du 19e siècle
comme en Allemagne ces zones
d'occupation vont bientôt dessiner la
division du pays au nord l'Union
soviétique installe kimilong en 1948
après les élections en forme de
plébiscite
[Musique]
au sud Washington met en place un
gouvernement à sa botte
deux ans plus tard en 1950
le jeune dirigeant de la Corée du Nord
décide de franchir le 38e parallèle et
de réunifier le pays par la force
[Musique]
c'est le début de la guerre de Corée
pour beaucoup d'historiens elle est la
plus féroce des guerres du 20e siècle
près de 5 millions de morts sur la
petite péninsule
rien ne semblait susceptible de freiner
la rage des combattants
le général McArthur commandant des
troupes du Sud sous les gîtes de l'ONU
souhaitent alors à son tour utiliser
l'harmonucléaire une nouvelle fois
kimilsum comprend l'importance
stratégique de la bombe
nucléaire nord-coréen ne date pas d'hier
c'était bien avant que l'Union
soviétique ne se soit effondrée la Corée
du Nord a très tôt voulu développer ses
armes nucléaires les Soviétiques ont
d'ailleurs plutôt tenté de les dissuader
dès lors la bombe devient l'obsession du
régime
la Corée du Nord a deux protecteurs la
Chine et l'Union soviétique qui a fait
exploser sa première bombe en 1949
[Musique]
qui me soumg va tout faire pour obtenir
les secrets nucléaires des deux grandes
puissances communistes
la Corée du Nord a mené une stratégie
diplomatique et plus distante des deux
superpuissances la Chine et l'URSS un
jour il se montre proche de Pékin et un
autre jour ils vont voir Moscou la Corée
du Nord est un tout petit pays qui a
très bien su profiter de la rivalité
entre les deux grandes puissances
en 1963 l'Union soviétique offre à la
Corée du Nord son premier réacteur
nucléaire un petit réacteur de recherche
installé à Young dans les montagnes au
milieu du pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la Corée du Nord est investie dans son
programme nucléaire depuis au moins les
années 70 voire 60
mon père était un ingénieur atomique
installement
70 à proximité d'un centre de recherche
et à cette époque on rencontrait de
nombreux chercheurs nord coréen qui
travaillaient là
[Musique]
au fil des années les espions américains
observent le développement de ce site de
Young
un développement impressionnant mais
qu'il inquiète pas vraiment la
communauté internationale
[Musique]
la Corée du Nord n'est alors pas encore
un état voyou
dans la sphère communiste pion est même
un exemple de développement rapide
[Musique]
kimilsung est un leader respecté qui
reçoit avec Fast les dirigeants du monde
entier
la Corée du Nord joue l'ouverture le
petit pays d'Asie de l'Est préfèrent
séduire plutôt qu'effrayé
le fondateur de la dynastie Kim reçoit
beaucoup à pianyang et il visite ces
pays frères notamment l'Allemagne de
l'Est
mais aussi la Roumanie de ce coup ces
deux meilleures alliés du monde
soviétique
mais tout va changer à la fin des années
80 le régime des Kim voit ses soutiens
disparaître il observe notamment avec
effroi la mort du couple tchao qui
dirigea la Roumanie pendant plus de 30
ans en utilisant des méthodes similaires
à celles des Kim
l'effondrement du bloc de l'Est va
couper Pione du reste du monde
à la fin de l'année 1989 je pense que
c'était en décembre fut un signal
dramatique pour le leadership
nord-coréen et je pense que c'est une
raison essentielle qui a empêché les
réformes et l'ouverture du pays
[Musique]
l'Union soviétique était le parrain de
l'accord et du Nord lui fournissant une
large assistance matérielle mais avec
l'effondrement de l'URSS se soutient a
disparu dans le même temps la Chine
souhaitait renforcer ses relations
diplomatiques avec la Corée du Sud le
Nord s'est senti isolé trahi et ils ont
senti qu'il devait prendre leur sécurité
en main et augmenter leur effort pour
développer des armes nucléaires
alors pour le régime des Kim la seule
solution est d'accélérer le programme
nucléaire l'expansion de Young cette
fois inquiète vraiment la communauté
internationale
sous pression la Corée accepte en 1992
les premières inspections de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie atomique
les Occidentaux espèrent forcer les
Coréens à stopper leur course à la bombe
[Musique]
ses chefs de la délégation il emmène les
spécialistes de la ioa à Pyongyang en
passant par Pékin car il n'y a pas de
vol direct puis ils ont inspecté Youn
c'est la première fois que des étrangers
sont entrés sur le fameux site de yoga
la Corée du Nord tente de camoufler son
programme de production de plutonium
mais la communauté internationale cette
fois ne peut plus fermer les yeux
faut respecter une inspection complète
du laboratoire radio-chimique n'a pas
été accepté dans les termes que nous
avions passés
en conséquence nous ne pouvons pas
exclure que cette installation
radio-chimique cette usine de
retraitement aient été opérationnelles
depuis février de l'an dernier
nous ne disons pas qu'elle a été nous ne
pouvons pas l'exclure
le président américain Bill Clinton se
rend sur la frontière entre les deux
Corées et il menace clairement pionnier
aucun intérêt pour eux à développer des
armes nucléaires parce que s'ils les
utilisent ce sera la fin de leur pays
[Musique]
si le régime des Kim continue son
développement militaire nucléaire
Washington utilisera la force
[Musique]
oui
stopper avant qu'il puisse faire jusqu'à
si bons nucléaires
et donc en tant que secrétaire à la
Défense j'ai fait une déclaration
publique disant que nous ne permettrions
pas à la Corée du Nord de retraiter le
combustible pour en faire des bombes
nucléaires
on était prêt à engager des actions
militaires pour éviter que ça arrive
à ce moment-là la presse nord-coréenne
m'a surnommée le maniaque de la guerre
sous pression américaine la Corée du
Nord accepte de signer un premier traité
de dénucléarisation
nous sommes en 1994 les États-Unis
pensent avoir éliminé la menace des Kim
j'ai été impliqué dans ces négociations
depuis le début des années 90 jusqu'à
nos jours et je constate beaucoup de
moments critiques
en 1994 les États-Unis et la Corée du
Nord ont signé un accord cadre qui a mis
le ola sur leur programme nucléaire
notamment la production de plutonium
militaire
qu'est-ce que la Corée du Nord a alors
fait
ils ont trouvé un autre moyen de
développer leur programme nucléaire de
façon clandestine
l'ingénieur pakistanais a développé une
technologie d'uranium hautement enrichie
le Pakistan a offert cette technologie
acquisition en échange il aura vendu des
missiles à longues et moyennes portées
un accord de non prolifération avec les
États-Unis tout en menant un autre
programme nucléaire clandestin
[Musique]
lorsque l'Amérique comprend le double
jeu de pioneyang Washington demande à
Pékin le meilleur allié de la Corée du
Nord de faire pression sur le régime des
Kim
[Musique]
dans le passé la Chine avait pu aider
dans les affaires nord-coréennes
nous présumions que la Chine partagée
notre point de vue que la Corée du Nord
n'est devait pas posséder d'un menu
clair qui pouvait rendre instable la
péninsule coréenne et
parce que nous présumions cet accord
avec la Chine nous avons pu travailler
ensemble dans les années 2000 à des
négociations nouvelles avec les pays
voisins également les négociations
[Musique]
après quelques tentatives ces
négociations à 6 échoueront comme toutes
les autres parce que la Corée du Nord
n'a aucune intention d'abandonner son
programme nucléaire mais également parce
que l'ailier chinois n'est pas toujours
entendu à Pione
[Musique]
du point de vue chinois la Corée du Nord
est un partenaire très difficile voire
un problème en soi
la course aux armements des pays voisins
la Corée du Sud ou le Japon est
justifiée par la menace nord-coréenne
tout comme la présence militaire
américaine
pour tout le monde que cette pente et en
puissance est en fait dirigée contre la
Chine
[Musique]
urs nord-coréens se rendent évidemment à
Pékin les parties communistes des deux
pays sont officiellement des parties
frères on maintient à chaque génération
des Kim l'apparence d'une entente
cordiale mais cette entente est d'abord
une nécessité pour les deux pays
pour la Corée du Nord depuis la chute du
monde soviétique seule la Chine peut
porter secours à son petit voisin
[Musique]
contrairement à ce que l'on pense la
Chine ne peut pas contrôler la Corée du
Nord un proverbe chinois dit que sans
lèvres les dents auront froid la Chine
serait donc embêtée si la Corée du Nord
n'existait pas ainsi la Corée du Nord
profite d'une immense autonomie
vis-à-vis de Pékin
a envoyé du riz 40 disait que la
population en Corée du Nord allait
mourir de faim elle permet à la Corée du
Nord de rester en vie pour la Chine la
Corée est une zone tampon un amortisseur
face au reste du monde
pour comprendre l'importance de la Corée
du Nord pour la Chine il faut considérer
l'attitude de Pékin avec l'ensemble de
ses voisins la Chine qui se dit en
mandarin le pays du milieu souhaite
bénéficier tout autour de son territoire
d'une zone tampon deux pays plus ou
moins vastalisés qui jouent un rôle de
protection pour le cœur du pays la
Mongolie le Tibet ou le signe Yang sont
ainsi les priorités stratégiques pour le
régime chinois qui souhaitent en les
contrôlant tenir ses ennemis à distance
de ses frontières c'est la même
stratégie qui impose à 6 gimping de
soutenir son turbulent voisin coréen
[Musique]
la Corée du Nord est pourtant le pays
qui a subi le plus de sanctions
économiques de la part de l'ONU
notamment depuis 2006 et son premier
essai nucléaire des sanctions votées par
la Chine au Conseil de sécurité qui
interdisent quasiment tout commerce avec
pionnier Yang mais au moment de les
appliquer Pékin préfère fermer les yeux
[Musique]
la Corée du Nord a lancé deux satellites
en 2012 et 2013
la Chine semblait se montrer coopérative
mais en réalité quand on arrive sur les
frontières trois mois ou 6 mois plus
tard on peut voir que les sanctions
n'étaient pas vraiment appliquées
la Russie et la Corée du Nord contre les
États-Unis et que cette alliance
triangulaire se solidifie voici une zone
de survie complètement nouvelle pour
Yang n'est-ce pas pour un pays aussi
petit que la Corée du Nord ces deux
grands pays la Chine et la Russie leur
fourniraient ainsi une marge de manœuvre
pour survivre
restriction du Conseil de sécurité ainsi
que les sanctions américaines n'auront
plus aucun effet résultat la Corée du
Nord pourra s'installer confortablement
comme un pays nucléaire sur la scène
internationale
[Musique]
la Chine a donc décidé de tolérer les
incartades de son turbulent voisin pour
mieux tenir à distance son ennemi
désigné les États-Unis
[Musique]
au sud du 38e parallèle qui a divisé les
deux corets l'armée américaine dispose
toujours aujourd'hui de 30 000 hommes
chargés de garantir la sécurité de la
Corée du Sud
[Musique]
en cas d'effondrement du Nord les dji se
trouveraient ainsi directement au
contact de la frontière chinoise un
scénario que pékin veut à tout prix
éviter
du gouvernement de la République
populaire
ce sont les États-Unis qui perturbent la
paix et la sécurité et nous entraîne
vers une situation dangereuse
[Musique]
a désigné notre pays comme cible d'une
frappe nucléaire préventive
une obsession américaine
chaque jour la propagande du régime s'en
prend à Washington
[Musique]
si les États-Unis déclenchent une guerre
sur notre sol nous détruirons le
territoire
américains
pourrait menacer leur dictature alors
ils agissent sans cesse la présumée
menace de Washington afin de souder la
population dans un réflexe patriotique
voilà comment la Corée fait face notre
agresseur n'évitera pas la mort
[Musique]
la Corée du Nord considère les
États-Unis comme la menace la plus
importante au monde
en effet leur propagande continue de
dire qu'ils ont gagné contre les
États-Unis pendant la guerre en Corée
entre 1950 et 1953
il continue de mener des provocations
agressives parfois militaires vis-à-vis
de Washington
malgré tout la Corée du Nord n'a pas
oublié son but ultime
[Musique]
établir des rapports diplomatiques avec
Washington en signant enfin la paix
en janvier 2017 Donald Trump devient le
45e président des États-Unis
ce président qui ne ressemble à aucun
autre semble prêt à exaucer le rêve de
Pione d'une restauration des relations
diplomatiques pourtant la relation entre
Donald Trump et Kim Jong-un avait bien
mal commencé
oui on commence avec la Corée du Nord
qui a lancé ce soir un nouveau missile
la Corée du Nord annonce avoir testé
avec succès un missile intercontinental
capable d'embarquer une charge nucléaire
le monde entier espérer que la Corée du
Nord n'en serait jamais capable une
Corée du Nord triomphante affirme que
son dernier test de missile balistique
démontre qu'elle a désormais la capacité
de frapper n'importe où aux États-Unis
[Musique]
en juillet 2017 la Corée du Nord teste
un nouveau missile balistique à porter
un terre-continental un missile dont la
portée théorique lui permet d'atteindre
le territoire américain
[Musique]
l'homme fusée s'est engagé dans une
mission suicide pour lui et pour son
régime
aujourd'hui le développement inconscient
d'harmonie nucléaire et de missiles
balistique par la Corée du Nord menace
le monde entier
ont une grande force et une grande
passion mais s'ils sont obligés de se
défendre ou de défendre leurs alliés
nous n'aurons pas d'autre choix que de
totalement détruire la Corée du Nord
[Musique]
septembre 2017 l'Assemblée générale de
l'ONU est sidéré par le discours du
nouveau président américain la réponse
va être cinglante
le bouton nucléaire est sur mon bureau
ce n'est pas du tout du chantage c'est
la réalité
en face de lui le président de la
première puissance mondiale l'homme le
plus puissant du monde menace ce petit
dictateur et se lance dans une drôle de
guerre des mots ça devrait être une
victoire facile pour Donald Trump et
bien pas du tout
comme c'est prédécesseurs Donald Trump
doit répondre aux provocations
nord-coréenne mais il décide de le faire
d'une manière totalement différente
[Musique]
ni leur propre citoyens ni même le droit
souverain de leur pays
si les nombreux justes
n'affrontent pas les quelques méchants
[Musique]
Trump ouvre la porte à une rencontre
avec Kim Jong-un malgré la vie
unanimement opposée de ses conseillers
quelques mois plus tard les deux hommes
se retrouvent ainsi à Singapour
[Musique]
c'est un leader à la personnalité
inconnue personne ne sait rien sur lui
je pense qu'il va nous surprendre et en
bien mais je l'ai déjà dit souvent qui
sait
vous savez que les gens disent qu'il est
possible de savoir si on va aimer
quelqu'un dans les cinq premières
secondes et bien je pense que très
rapidement je vais savoir si quelque
chose de positif va arriver
[Musique]
aux États-Unis on dit souvent que le
président Trump a eu tort de s'abaisser
à établir une relation avec Kim Jong-un
des gala égale mais si on reste sur ce
genre de position alors la question du
programme nucléaire ne va jamais se
régler
[Musique]
c'est une rencontre historique
l'aboutissement des efforts de la
dynastie Kim
voulez-vous dire quelque chose à la
presse
aujourd'hui nous vivons une rencontre
historique
nous signons un traité qui enterre notre
passé difficile et qui annonce un
nouveau départ
mais le résultat de ce sommet est
surtout symbolique
[Musique]
merci beaucoup c'est fantastique malgré
les sourires les deux leaders ont signé
un document d'attention sans aucune
portée pratique
les négociations doivent véritablement
commencer à Hanoï au Vietnam pour une
seconde rencontre programmée quelques
mois plus tard et cette fois-ci Kim
Jong-Un a décidé de jouer son bateau
a fait une proposition c'est une
proposition unilatérale il proposait de
fermer Yong Yang
une fermeture en échange de la
suppression de la plupart des sanctions
américaines
c'était déséquilibré et l'administration
Trump a eu raison de refuser
mais je pense que si les États-Unis
avaient répondu avec une proposition
réaliste alors on aurait peut-être fait
des progrès
mais là Kim Jong-Un a quitté Hanoï
humilié on lui avait dit que les
Américains allaient accepter sa
proposition
mais ils l'ont balayé d'en revers de la
main
et depuis un œil en 2019 il n'y a plus
eu de progrès et la Corée du Nord a
refusé tous les efforts américains de
reprendre un dialogue
[Musique]
persuadé qu'aucun accord ne sera
possible avec l'Occident la Corée du
Nord c'est ainsi repliée sur elle-même
royaume-hermite séparé du reste du monde
par la zone des militarisée qui divise
toujours les deux Corées autour du 38e
parallèle
une zone étanche un franchissable depuis
un no man's land seulement parcouru par
les patrouilles des deux armées
on s'observe parfois on voit passer
quelques balles perdues
c'est la dernière frontière de la guerre
froide
[Musique]
par endroits des observatoires
permettent au coréen du sud de jeter un
regard vers leurs ennemis du Nord
il n'y a pas grand chose à voir à part
quelques villages potamines
[Musique]
ces au-delà de ces montagnes que
pianyang a caché son arsenal
des milliers de missiles pointés versés
ou qui n'est qu'à 30 km de là
dans la grande capitale du Sud 25
millions d'habitants la population se
prépare une fois par mois à la colère du
Nord
[Musique]
ici les stations de métro sont autant
d'abris où l'on stocke des masques
anti-arme chimiques ou des rations de
survie
bien avant de devenir une puissance
nucléaire la Corée du Nord avait fait la
promesse de la destruction de Séoul sa
première assurance vie
[Musique]
on est toujours en état de guerre et
cette situation ou cette permanence
d'une situation je dirais
d'instabilité fondamentale
je pense est très ancré dans la vision
du monde et les rapports ou la vision
que peut avoir la Corée du Nord de ces
relations avec le sud et de ses
relations plus encore avec l'ennemi
traditionnel l'ennemi historique mais
qui reste les États-Unis
avant même d'avoir un programme actif
d'armes nucléaire pion possédait au
moins 10 000 pièces d'artillerie à
portée de Séoul
donc une intervention militaire contre
le programme nucléaire pouvait provoquer
une destruction massive et meurtrière de
la vie
alors la Corée du Nord a continué son
relâche son unique but de devenir une
puissance nucléaire
[Musique]
face à la menace la Corée du Sud hésite
parfois entre deux stratégies
la première stratégie c'est l'alignement
total avec les États-Unis
régulièrement l'armée de Séoul et les
soldats de Washington montrent leurs
muscles
des exercices médiatiques censé
illustrer la détermination de l'Amérique
à défendre coûte que coûte la Corée du
Sud
mais cette stratégie conventionnelle
a-t-elle encore un sens avec une Corée
du Nord puissance atomique
[Musique]
la deuxième stratégie de la Corée du Sud
c'est de tenter un rapprochement avec le
Nord
en l'an 2000 pour la première fois Kim
Jong-il rencontre Kim Djon le premier
président sud-coréen issu du parti
démocrate à gauche de l'échiquier
politique à Séoul
depuis chaque président de gauche a
tenté de se rapprocher de la dynastie
des Kim
[Musique]
le dernier épisode de ces sommets
Nord-Sud a débuté en 2018 à l'occasion
des Jeux olympiques de pianchang en
Corée du Sud mesdames et messieurs merci
d'accueillir le président de la
République de Corée Mounji et le
président pour la première fois les
sportifs des deux pays parades sous une
bannière commune
c'est un moment important dans
l'histoire olympique alors que les
athlètes de Corée du Nord et du Sud sont
réunis dans une seule équipe derrière le
drapeau de la péninsule coréenne
la délégation nord-coréenne est conduite
par un vétéran du régime qui m'younam
mais la vraie sensation et la présence
de kimiot Jong la jeune sœur du
dictateur du Nord
c'est la première fois qu'un membre de
la famille au pouvoir mais les pieds au
sud depuis la séparation en 1945 et la
jeune femme fait l'objet de toutes les
attentions
elle fait de facto office de ministre
des Affaires étrangères et va réussir à
séduire l'opinion publique sud-coréenne
joue le rôle de numéro 2 du régime c'est
assez nouveau en Corée du Nord
avant c'était qui premier
mais c'est désormais une relation dans
une fratrie ces nouveaux sous Kim
Jong-un
si jamais quelque chose arrive à Kim
Jong-un qui pourrait jouer son rôle et
le remplacer
à la tribune de la cérémonie d'ouverture
elle est placée juste derrière Mike
pence le vice-président américain mais
lorsque les athlètes américains passent
devant la tribune la délégation
nord-coréenne reste glaciale
c'est le président sud-coréen mundgine
qui a tout organisé il est lui aussi
membre du Parti démocrate à gauche de
l'échiquier politique au sud et il
voulait renouer avec la politique
d'ouverture de Kim Djon
[Musique]
la visite de kimbioge ne se limite ainsi
pas à l'ouverture des JO
[Musique]
elle est très politique
dès son arrivée à l'aéroport de Séoul la
venue de la sœur du dictateur
nord-coréen et lectrice la Corée du Sud
[Musique]
la descendante de la famille Kim est
accueilli à la maison bleue la
présidence sud-coréenne à Séoul
l'instant exceptionnel est suivi en
direct par tous les Sud-Coréens
[Musique]
l'image de ces retrouvailles est encore
plus forte lorsque Nord Est sud-coréen
se retrouve ensuite pour encourager leur
équipe commune tout un symbole lors d'un
match de hockey sur glace contre la
Suisse
[Musique]
tout est fait pour donner l'impression
d'une fraternisation
[Musique]
après la rencontre olympique un sommet
est organisé entre Kim Jong-un et le
président sud-coréen munji
on se retrouve sur la DMZ où l'on
franchise symboliquement la bande de
béton qui symbolise la frontière
[Musique]
je suis très ému nous nous rencontrons à
cet endroit historique et vous êtes venu
m'accueillir en personne
[Musique]
l'atmosphère est franchement détendue et
Kim Jong-un montre au média du Sud qu'il
possède un certain sens de l'humour mais
aussi un respect confusé un de son aîné
le président du Sud
[Musique]
jamais dans l'histoire entre les deux
corets un rapprochement n'a semblé si
proche
pourtant ce n'est qu'un feu de paille
[Applaudissements]
et quand notre
du Nord a observé avec beaucoup
d'attention la relation entre les deux
Allemagnes ils sont parfaitement
prévenus tant que la Corée du Nord est
significativement plus faible que la
Corée du Sud du point de vue économique
alors la Corée du Sud représentera
toujours une menace pour le
nord-coréenne vis-à-vis du Sud et de
construire une relation plus équilibrée
[Musique]
mais dans la vie économique cela reste à
faire
[Musique]
notre camarade adoré Kim Jong-Un a
dirigé en personne sur le terrain
l'essai de lancement du nouveau missile
balistique intercontinental la grande
force militaire de la République
démocratique populaire de Corée
chaque jour la télévision du Pione
raconte l'histoire de ce petit pays qui
se veut légal des grandes puissances
la Corée du Nord a dépensé jusque 25% de
son PIB pour s'offrir son arsenal
nucléaire désormais son obsession est
tournée vers les missiles balistiques
intercontinentaux
le journal télévisé chaque soir propose
des mises en scène toujours plus
innovantes
le grand leader est à la manœuvre
parfois façon générale en chef et
parfois façon Top Gun
le but ultime de la Corée du Nord c'est
de bien vivre développer leur économie
leur puissance leur système de
protection sociale le meilleur moyen
pour réussir selon eux c'est le
nucléaire c'est une course contre la
montre ils veulent tenir encore un peu
pour que leur système ne puisse plus
être menacé
puis il y aura d'armes nucléaires encore
et du Nord et moins ce sera facile de
négocier avec eux
on entend souvent que le temps joue
contre la Corée du Nord car leur
économie est instable leur régime
politique n'est pas solide
mais regardez ce qui s'est passé ces 30
dernières années le temps joue vraiment
notre faveur
comme le régime nord-coréen ne s'est pas
effondré leur volonté nucléaire devient
de plus en plus solide les sanctions
internationales sont de moins en moins
efficaces alors le temps ne joue pas
pour l'Occident il semble plus favorable
pour la Corée du Nord
[Musique]
le reportage se termine toujours de la
même manière sur la télévision d'État le
lancement du missile est une réussite
l'Amérique et ses alliés sont prévenus
le cher camarade Kim Jong-Un a déclaré
que l'armée de la République populaire
démocratique de Corée est pleinement
préparé à contrer et à contenir
rigoureusement toutes les mesures de
sanction militaires dangereuses des
impérialistes américains
[Musique]
le programme nucléaire est ainsi devenu
essentiel pour le régime
c'est un outil domestique pour
convaincre la population de la puissance
du pays
[Musique]
c'est aussi une assurance vie familiale
vis-à-vis du reste du monde
après avoir soumis son peuple la
dynastie qui m'espère désormais tenir en
respect le reste du monde
[Musique]